[Music]
gigi hadid Faith Hill and Tim McGraw all
on Fridays Ellen when I moved to New
York I wanted to have a boat cover I
wanted to be on Food Network and I
wanted to be on Ellen
it's the 21 year olds Ellen debut she
reveals how quickly she and Zayn Malik
fell for each other during date one over
a year ago we played it cool for at like
10 minutes and I was like you're really
cute and then that was it no bi we
connected like really quickly and just
he is really cute and like just started
like yeah we had the kind of the same
sense of humor insurance sharing videos
Gigi echoed the same sentiment to ET a
months ago he's obviously so gorgeous
but really the way that we could have
conversations and kind of just were
really interested in the same things and
it was really easy and faith and Jim
brought the laughs playing never have I
ever
I never have I ever used my spouse's
toothbrush without telling them ever
fallen asleep during sexy time yeah like
I'm bringing sexy back baby or something
I don't know I'm sure I have never never
have I ever Snoop through my spouse's
belongings without them knowing
[Applause]